[Music]
welcome to the Samuel Leeds podcast this
episode we're gonna be talking in
property I'm gonna be explaining exactly
what I've been up to this week
it's been a crazy week I hope you find
this interesting enjoyable entertaining
and informative what I know who is crazy
exhausted yep you know what when you
when you commit to do things like this
podcast every week work out with Marvin
every day sometimes I think it was I
said either you've got to be disciplined
in life or else life will discipline you
it's true so it's like here we are doing
this podcast like what are you doing
straight after this I'll tell you after
this yeah great right probably a
horrible 1 hour
yeah workout I don't even want to think
about it yeah yeah well I think about it
that's more painful for longer letting
this be one hour but what a great week
and so tell us a bit about so we had a
dinner yes tell me about that don't know
wait two days ago
yes two days ago it was a winner's
Wednesday dinner so every week we have a
student come on winners Wednesday and
now this is popularly if I B's let me
call Emilio Sante bum-bum-bum I'd yeah
you and you're running dinners so I was
fantastic yeah it was so nice you know
what most of my friends are my success
students and just being in a room with
32 people that are financially free
having a three-course dinner with topic
topping up wine yeah I was just
I just loved every second of it and I
think as well from a networking
perspective joint ventures inspiration
it was really quite emotional so yeah
all the time
I think every six months yes so we're
gonna have a one is Wednesday dinner
every six months yeah and I get was
credible like the feedback like
everyone's post on the group but
pictures of themselves Everest would
connect in which is exactly what we
wanted
I wanted to make it more of a community
sir and I think everyone should do
something like this
you should have a dinner at least every
six months and invite the most
successful people that you know yeah
down to the dinner
I'm pay the bill pay the bill you know
and and just be around good people
yeah do the make up of the people that
you spend the most time with
and for me as well selfishly I really
enjoyed but also I think it's important
to give for me and you to give our time
back to people yeah as well that say I
loved it was great yeah the bill was
expensive but it was great worth it cuz
everyone loved it yeah and then straight
after that we went to Liverpool Amelia
that we finished a like 11 yeah in
London then we drive p.m. then we drove
we got to live a more like three o'clock
yeah 3 a.m. yeah and then we had a few
hours sleep and then boom we were
viewing houses all day Liverpool yeah
we're meetings view houses we finished
about 3 p.m. then we drove to the crash
course in London Heathrow I usually got
out of the car and went on stage I got
pranked real bad on stage that was
horrendous
I hate your doing that talk about the
plane so basically Samuel is a bit of a
prankster always pranking people so
thank you I think yeah you will die over
oh yeah that's true I pretended your
bedroom was something else yeah look
like a dog bed ok I was like that's not
really yeah but anyway so yeah built the
lead up to it was the it was literally a
few years ago now and he still holds a
grudge man Russell had nine points on
his license and he was desperately
waiting for five years to pass and then
his license gets wiped and it was like
four years and 10 months oh my gosh and
he was driving really carefully when I
lose his license because if you get 12
points you lose your licence and I sent
him a letter pretending to be the police
probably illegal
I better get done for it now potentially
the police telling him that he got he'd
been seen speeding and he had three
points and literally yep he was almost
sobbing this is like so and I was
you seen the letter is he not and I
waited a few hours and then I caught him
I posit ok and he was like and he on the
phone to my dad for hours like trying to
work out how to dispute I felt so bad
but I also thought it was hilarious and
that's why he's now out for revenge
he got revenge last night he called me
in the morning and was like we're gonna
prank Samuel I'm gonna tell you more
about when you get here but basically
he's gonna walk on stage and nobody's
gonna clap nobody's so much worse no
even and I thought are somebody or
somebody what's up it the audience were
great for tip up so so when I got back
from Liverpool to driving for four hours
yeah I go backstage how much and you are
like this guy and you took me outside
yeah well they were announcing it so
everyone right and then I come onstage
and normally it's like you know welcome
Samuel is like alone people usually
collab and cheer maybe you can stand up
yeah you know and the muses will pump in
and on Arkell and then I'll say you know
how's it been today you know Chad and it
was really engaged excited and they'll
teach him loads about property yeah well
yeah came as crickets but before I even
asked a question or even it was just it
was just silent and I was thinking what
the heck yeah I think we've got the
footage if someone was feeling we need
to publish that yeah we started maybe we
don't publish I probably stupid and I
was like why was I was just silent just
looking at me blank and I just thought I
missed something like is there and I was
it was just the most Awkward horrible I
think I just felt the life leave my body
and I just was like why and then I think
I just by then picture balls been
pranked and I was like it is a prank and
then Russell came out but that was crazy
and then we yeah I enjoy I enjoyed the
bit before where I was getting you to
exercise outside yeah well sort of like
you need you need to make some of your
got sides I need to tell the audience so
I was thinking how can I possibly get
outside so that's something we need to
go outside you've not worked out with
Marvin today you saw trainer I was like
you need to do some jumps we've been sat
in the car so you were there doing John
stargell name is funny dude I'll take
you well yeah you pick it well I find it
funny I was like how is he gonna take it
I've message the air Russell halfway
through the day like it's all good so
the houses that we did Liverpool houses
with you pay channels yeah we viewed a
service accommodation unit a little
block with a few serviced accommodation
units in it we viewed a really cheap
house which is going to be a buy
refurbish refinance opportunity and we
viewed a development opportunity we've
like commercial mix juice and that was a
that was in Burnley and all the others
were in Liverpool so which one was your
favorite house oh I did a loved one in
Burnley the one in Burns is interested
in the fact bit like it they had it
estate agents as well and Wells owner
all grew up I think their last two on my
favorite I think what did you learn what
did you learn this yesterday so fast um
I mean the main thing that I learned is
there's like three main things that
you're looking out for okay so we'll do
one at a time you do the first one
okay scene is like how much you put in
yeah yeah how much second thing is any
fees and referred fix it was development
cost development cost your business so
that yeah the first thing is what's the
purchase price second thing is how much
is it gonna cost a refurb yeah and then
and then ultimately yeah or the end
value valuation so we were just
crunching numbers and getting those
figures yeah and what's your role
because you do help me probably stuff
like I know obviously we've got
surveyors and this but you really have
your kind of like you talk a lot of
agents
ya know who's interested like booking so
I help booked some of the viewings yeah
and kind of go like you're like power to
you people and like help them book stuff
yeah um for Wednesday who are you
me talent manager I just say your
manager yeah
like but your talent manager so you
basically do everything yeah
tell them it's just if I don't think I
have a job does like work/life balance
it's it's I feel like for a lot of
people I think they enjoy current
nine-to-five and being at work and then
off work and they know when they finish
work they can kind of they don't have to
be contacted that's better yeah it's
like what people prefer but I think for
me and how I am I'm quite I'm an
all-or-nothing kind of person so for me
I don't mind doing like crazy long days
on this stuff to do and but then I just
want to know that when I need a day off
what I can feel I'm like mmm I'm Dre
your body tells you yeah yeah and that's
how I like to work so I think we kind of
like in the company it's very like you
let people kind of work how they want
and I think in a situation of how we
work like even like last night we were
up to like what 3 no no no we were up
till 5 last night look at my clock in
the end like we've been having like 2
hours sleep a night yeah it's crazy
which is just insane do you know what I
kind of think when I think of because
people say are you gonna burn out I know
Grant Cardone
who's kind of men talking at the moment
he says you're not gonna burn out you're
not a candle right but here's the thing
when you're exercising everything's
gonna relate back to exercising now
because of what is all this it consumes
me but when you're exercising
do you know you've got good and you've
got bad hurt John I mean by that okay so
if I'm doing squats and I can feel it
burning yeah I'm feeling oh it's burning
but it's a healthy man but then if I
feel at all it's like really painful on
my knees oh yeah I said oh that's not
good and if you push through that kind
of pain it's gonna get worse it's
actually going to make you injured
whereas the burn is like yeah do it
so it's depending on the type of pain
you can know if it's healthy or not and
I think we've working really hard
sometimes your body will just tell you
enough you need a day out you need
a couple days or whatever it might be
because you think you know what I'm an
over myself l if I keep doing this I'm
actually getting really
I'm not functioning well I'm not and
that's when it's like time out recharge
and the same way you recharge your phone
it's like I need to recharge but I think
when it's just like okay I'm really
tired and really and it's crazy busy and
I'm hectic but actually you're growing
through it and it's fun and you enjoying
it it's like well why do you need to
stop why do you need to say oh actually
I need to time I know it's good yeah I
think just self-awareness just
understanding one uni time yeah I kind
of think what did you think of that
video that I put up which some people
said was actually pointed at you which
one the nine-to-five obviously what you
do you feel the spot in these podcasts
to make things all good for me so you
can explain more so yeah I mean
basically I put a video out on you know
because we put a video out saying about
how employees should act if they want to
be successful and how that should almost
act as business people they should be
placed themselves and as if it's their
own business and then actually what
happens they'll go really far the video
doesn't really what I think it got like
how many of you does that happening
15,000 I think 15,000 a few days and
it's getting so much you love that video
which surprised me because I think that
a lot of my videos people think that I'm
bashing jobs or I'm bashing employees
like I'm saying or become financially
free you don't want a job actually that
is that's not my message I've got a job
I employ myself like I'm not against
jobs what I'm against is I'm against
Notts people not living to their
potential what I'm against them against
people being in a job where they can't
grow and they look at the watch and a
five o'clock they leave and they're
caught watching and they do that until
they're 67 that's sad that's a sorry
existed I hate that and there's another
way and property is just a vehicle but
actually I encourage people to be in a
job that they enjoy where they can grow
make as much money as they can and then
invest smile on the side and grow a
passive income or create a leg that's
but that's just just great yeah so my
message to my own members of staff like
you and me and everybody here my message
to my own members of staff is actually
the exact same message to my students
don't eaching about property it's not a
different message yeah it might be
slanted different because most of the
people that maybe come to the crash
course there might be a lot of people
that come and all want to get on the job
whereas I'd like to think that with
people within my team that actually love
their job and I think most people do yes
so it might be a different side to the
coin but actually the the message is
congruent and if it wasn't I wouldn't be
able to grow a big team and I wouldn't
be able to grow and it kind of kind of
like freaks me out a bit when I see big
entrepreneurs bashing employees and it's
like but you employ people how can you
bashing 3si into your team exactly how
can you be like our employees that's
stupid it's like what how can you how
can and it's just not true 80% of
business owners fail in the first five
years and the 20% that succeed on paper
succeed all that means is they didn't go
bankrupt I didn't closed the business
but probably they end up on less than
the minimum wage
so that's hard but being and being in a
good career I think it's great so I
think it's an interesting video but I've
got quite passionate in the video and I
was I was kind of annoyed in the video
about people but our employees with a
employee mindset rather than being a
member of staff with an entrepreneur's
mindset and when I put the video it's
all coming on nothing oh but I posted it
and I was advised by HR they were like
yeah because he might look
time-sensitive what did you think the
video I thought was good in we said it
wasn't even known to you the talk was it
wink wink
but you know what though I must say
yourself and everybody in the team like
have such a good attitude and I'm just
like and we sat around people now here
like I am so just impressed everybody in
the team going through the bad times as
well as the good times yeah I mean some
of you guys like Nick Nick he was in the
room he came on actually he worked for
my brother's company then when me and my
brother teamed up moved to a company
then moved house to London it's like the
kind of commitment and you you moved
from Manchester to water Hampton and in
the following month what happened
someone removed offices to London yeah
and you were homeless you could have
been the financial freedom Challenge
closely
I'd been bugs in the bucket your call
and you were like gather well yeah
basically I had all my stuff in bin box
yeah I just finished uni so I was like
fully no money really suitcase I like my
pillows and stuff in bin bags and then I
come over we had some you basically
moved me down to London we were doing
some work so in an out of hotels and
then there's we were like on the road
yeah it's just living honestly and you
know there's a point at which I was I
probably need somewhere to live and so I
end up actually staying at someone's
house for like a week and a half I think
and then it went into an air B&B with
another one of their employees and then
got my own place yeah
so it was a journey but we're gonna do a
podcast at some point and little bits
come out but I wanna I want to talk to
you
someone mm-hmm about the whole
experience yeah from how you found out
about us yeah we found out about you
what happened because it's an incredible
story but why don't you give me the know
sure why not yes so I basically you post
that you wanted a videographer yeah and
you were given an email post before that
oh yeah okay I'll go back no you were
good even but you posted and you said
like I think yeah so basically I came my
mom's into property but she was doing
the traditional wrong kind of way where
she was doing the BRR and she would
basically buy a house do it up sell it
but always gets up with why she was
really struggling for money just before
she
so I was like oh there must be a better
way to do this that's when I came across
you and that's when we came to crash
course
from there we booked on the DfE and I
was all good I'd kind of been watching
and I was a yes well I paid for it well
luckily enough I did installments I got
the last ones oh well yeah I actually
won the on the viral video the first FF
challenge because you wrote the
description which is crazy
so yeah that's how you got on my radar
yes the very first time yeah and I was
just keeping up-to-date with stuff we
even found them a post that I had done
like a comment had done on Nick's video
and his Uganda documentary I remember
watching it when I was like in the
middle of writing my dissertation and I
had wrote something because he was like
upset they think as many views it's an
amazing piece of content if you haven't
watched it you meet him people don't
watch that kind of stuff because he
doesn't show how to make money yeah save
us a Oh his his documentary about what I
did in Africa people like yeah we don't
get yeah not everybody for most people
yeah yeah which is a shame but far
enough but then it's like here's me
becoming financially free from scratch
that will go viral yeah I just want
people to say yeah and I come into like
I was commenting as I was watching it
it's nothing it for like really three
comments and I quote accompany if this
video you didn't get this many views
it's an amazing piece of content and
it's funny because we found it through
the day I saw the messages from like
eight years ago
yes we even mean you yes she messaged me
on Facebook I love doing that I love
going like Alastair Ricky man yo Antony
John Wilmot all these people that are
now like really really really close
friends of mine and then I'll go right
to the bottom of the Facebook messages
and they reached out and Facebook and
they're like oh I'm trying to book on
the crash course but the links not
working or something I've booked on are
you gonna be there and then I just want
to say thank so much fantastic and it's
just like from going from almost just
like a fan yeah yeah to a friend yeah
he's just so weird and that's what all
the stories were like at the winners
dinner yeah
everyone was like okay so they'd be
people sat in the room that they'd be
like I first initially he owns the crash
course because I saw this person's
winner and there was
across the table for them I like
obviously everyone was there yeah the
rippling effect but like someone would
like I came to the crash course and join
the Academy as a result of watching John
reybold's video and John Reybold is
across the table thank you John and then
someone would then say and I came
because of your video and it's like the
organic snowballing effect of growth and
success from people sharing their
stories as a result of coming through
the training is phenomenal yeah it was
insane it was just crazy and like people
that come to the crash course now it's
like you might be there in six months
and it's just crazy in a year's time
we're gonna have another like 52 winners
oh wait every week because you put a
post up on Facebook group yes so
basically from from then I had
University so I had like my dissertation
to do and all that kind stuff and when I
finished I was obviously looking for a
job and you'd put a post on Facebook
about head I thought post for no I think
I think you put a post at first and you
it was it was like I don't know what to
do my favorite crossroads yeah and it
was a bit like oh I'm stuck in a rut
kind of post yeah University the sort of
thing you're doing you you've got
nothing else to do in the afternoon and
then all I remember seeing it I know
actually I hate to admit it but I
remember sort of I think you know I
thought of myself
oh but in a my in my defense but I was
like I was like oh at least I'll have
the confidence to write it because
initially I would never normally do that
fair enough I was like because I
remember I think I was going for some
interview or something it was to do with
property yeah I was actually going and
to be fair what you said there's nothing
wrong with it at all but yeah I just was
a bit like yeah yeah then all I maybe a
week later or a few days later it
happened to post saying I'm looking for
a videographer yeah you apply yeah no I
didn't even apply you put it up and I
said if you're ever up because you were
like four in London and videographer in
London and I was like I'm not in London
um but you know if you ever need any
help filming up north I'm here like for
free forever just so you know I'm here
you
message me on Facebook oh yeah no no you
weren't
so you message me off an agenda as you
were commenting on everything all the
post and I liked you you come into the
DfE you'd written the financial freedom
convinced the DFA yet
oh you hadn't but but I crash girl sorry
but I was just kind of like oh she's
cool you know commenting nice good
energy I suppose when you know no
because when you posted that when you
message me yeah I know if you need to
help your Manchester or whatever let me
know I think she searched her name and I
think I found your YouTube channel brand
yeah our brand yeah and I thought this
lady has it got a really good energy and
she's pretty cool I think she'd be a
great videographer cuz you're putting
your own videos I anyway so then I
messaged you and I said I don't remember
what I said but I just I think you said
something that all you could know why
did it I said are you free for a call
yeah and then you responded and said yes
I called you immediately yeah and said
are you a good videographer you said
yeah how many minutes did it take me
like two minutes and I was just like
what you doing on Monday yeah this was
the Thursday this is Thursday night yeah
we did on Monday you're like don't know
I was like when you can start working
full-time for the company on Monday I'll
meet you in Doncaster you can start
filming that day and I was like what
this is crazy is that finish eating why
struttin holiday to Mexico that was
literally the first week that was just
kind of like okay coming back to reality
I need a job that happened I was in Eden
for the weekend because actually I said
when I did some stuff for my cousin for
a wedding yeah and then on the Monday in
Doncaster with a backpack and a camera
and that was it and now you've gone from
videographer you but I don't think you
were like I just understood the value of
videography which is why I learned the
skill I mean with the guys that's the
thing yeah well is you you were good
yeah it wasn't modern alloys
[Music]
you know yeah you want to change job you
can just change over there the same come
yeah I just found for me I'm a little
person I'm not I won't take over from
something to be leadership in something
if like it's going all well like you
might see someone leading a team or
leading something and it's going all
well I'm very happy they joked about it
yeah I think they were happy for me cuz
I think I think I filled a niche and it
helps them yeah because what I'm doing
now you're giving them stuff to fill me
yeah yeah literally say like a foods I'm
for my role now as talent manager I will
basically anyone that comes on a YouTube
channel yeah I will look after I'll get
people on the channel so any like
celebrities experts winners I once a
Samuel I can look after so that kind of
thing so it helps them yeah because it's
a problem usually what's your vision in
2020 you 2020 vision for this role yeah
well just you in general within the
company whatever what's your 2020 vision
my vision isn't very strong powerful
businesswoman um I want to just become
like the best of my job yeah I don't
believe anybody is kind of like
irreplaceable but I just want to be so
valuable you become replaceable yes yeah
why what do you want to replace yourself
because if you don't like say if I kept
all this information on cell saver I was
learning how to do stuff learning how to
talk to influences look what kept myself
didn't write a manual didn't tell people
cuz I was like oh if I tell people then
you can easily get rid of me sore thing
yeah then but then all that would happen
is someone get employed above me yeah so
basically head of my department you know
the starts expanded true and actually I
would want to be at the point where I
have a mile what I can train people and
I'm bringing people on under me yeah so
yeah get promoted unless you replace
yourself yeah and that's as a employee
an entrepreneur a business owner a
leader aren't always replacing myself
constantly base in myself and I think
that if you want to go really far and if
you're specialists it might be a bit
different like for instance if you're an
accountant you want to be the best
however you might not want to replace
yourself you'd want to be a specialist
but if you want to have a team under you
and stuff then of course you need to
replace yourself you need to be a
trainer trainer and a leader are
actually the same thing so yeah I think
you did really well
I'm really excited what's it what's it
been like working with me over the last
six months yeah loved it it just they
work a lot I think a lot can be said for
working for a company where you align
with their values and you align with how
the kind of role goes like I think at
the start because we were very much like
as we are now you know 24/7 filming on
the road kind of thing and then when we
moved to London it was a little bit more
like office bays 9:00 to 5:00 for a
while so I had kind of like a taste of
both I think for me definitely I fit
more in there like on the road here and
now kind of lifestyle just my person I
can go into the media team you know
there's like five six videographers and
I can say you know oh I'm gonna be doing
this adventure on Saturday I'm gonna be
and some people want to come I wouldn't
love to come but I well but but it's
almost like why force somebody to try
and it's better I think it's better as a
leader to let people do what they want
to do what they love rather than trying
to put people in boxes give people
titles and jobs and restrictions
actually just hey let's let's grow let's
love this go together
yeah you know the same way of trying to
get me to do something like an admin
role I wouldn't love it I'd rather be
working on different stuff I think it's
the same within the company yeah and I
just think your management styles suits
me quite well in terms of for example if
you wanted me to do something you know
that shouting at me or talking a certain
tone that would never get me to do
something as soon as somebody is like
disaffected or I'm to like my ears just
turn on so how do i how do i as your I
guess leader yeah you know yeah you
manage me by like say if you really want
me to do something you would obviously
just ask me and just be like this is
super urgent I need to do this if I
wasn't doing again you would say again
and I think I don't think there's ever
been a time where you've kind of said oh
really nice to this thing you kept
saying that I'm just like completely
ignored it I think having a heart full
of gratitude for everybody and a priest
creation for all of the team everybody I
think that is for me I think their
number one thing if you if you if you're
an int I said don't be an entitled as an
employee but also don't mean entitled as
a boss or manager if you're entitled
expect and you know I just are you gonna
be grateful pre appreciative for people
are not the team hold me together the
mess support me surround me I think I
mean there are times when I do
micromanage I think maybe small times
probably would say that you know oh man
that common ease changing you know the
tiniest things cuz I know exactly how I
want it so I almost think leaving people
I'm not gonna be involved you just do
whatever has its merit but also I think
I think it's hard cuz you've kind of
delegated boy it's like it's
irresponsible I think for a entrepreneur
to basically have a business status
mustn't do that but don't ever check it
don't ever advise it cuz kind of
responsible because then if it all goes
wrong why have you not been helping why
have you not been if yeah I'm also you
know we get I get feedback from you guys
you know I do better and stuff like that
so yeah and it's just a great privilege
to be in the company you know on the
property side on the media side I have
all my different worlds with different
people you know tell me about that so
you're saying you have different what so
for example with a conversation with me
we might be talking about like
influences celebrities that are reaching
out and then with them hey char we're
talking about more like a char store
yeah your whole world is influencers
Talent
yes yeah man like booking me in for
speaking engagements all the stuff and
that's your world and I have the whole
world with you yeah Russell
he'd be like sales and finance yeah
income and numbers and figure if you go
Russell we've just had this amazing
collaboration with this influencer he
won't be interested but if you went and
it's resulted in this show me the
numbers yeah you know I went to
Liverpool yesterday we had a great time
we did it we got
holman done he's like yeah but did you
get a deal yeah what sort of that I mean
would care but he's more you know and
then and then with other people it's
like or has everyone getting arm like
I'm talking to a mate just by holding
the staff whose is everyone happy that's
kind of her well yeah and I'm kinda just
you know a finger in every world
depending on the day of the week which
to prefer my favorite stuff
oh my favorite stuff that's a really
hard I think for me it has to be variety
I mean I I do love the media stuff yeah
you do the YouTube videos I'm a sound
that cuz mix right here yes I love the
media stuff yeah I love that and I think
I also really enjoy just seeing people
impact it okay you know so if it just
like the winners when's the stuff that
you do as well on the property side I
really really enjoy talking to a
property director and just seen the
deals and he's ah just awesome yeah I
just I don't know depends on what day
than when you catch me so that's caught
listen how I've really your so called
and I think next time who do you want to
select for the podcast next time I'm
like I'm thinking Nick Nick yeah I think
Nick would have some good stories yeah
would you spend 45 minutes just dissing
you I think yeah potentially we probably
would but listen Corp guest coming on
that yes we got love him yeah
Marvin might I'm gonna bring my personal
trainer on but also he got some back
yeah yeah got loads of celebrities we're
working with big names a lot of
footballers some pop stars and there's
some people have said they'd love to go
on the podcast which is really cool yeah
so before I wouldn't have even been able
to manage all of the emails that I get
from all of these people but now I have
you to keep the relationships to answer
the messages is great so guys I hope you
enjoyed the podcast I hope you've got a
lot of valuable information as well as
entertainment from me and Amelia a
Sunday and we look forward to seeing you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]